The first step is to have a Twinmotion project ready.
Use the TM2UE Twinmotion file that's been provided to you.
You also need an Unreal Engine project on the receiving end.
But before you create one, you will need to install a dedicated Twinmotion plugin.
Use the Epic Games Launcher to access Marketplace.
Look up the plugin named Datasmith Twinmotion Content for Unreal Engine.
Install it to Unreal Engine. In my case, I've already installed it to the 5.3 version.
Next, start UE5 and create a new project using the blank architectural template and name it TM2UE5.
First order of business is to ensure the plugin is enabled.
Go to the plugin's dialog and search for Twinmotion.
Enable the Datasmith Twinmotion Content plugin you just installed and restart the project.
Once that's done, close the plugin's dialog and create a new default level.
Set the Sun and Sky to a more reasonable intensity of 100 lux.
Adjust the post-process volume's exposure to a more constant setting.
Delete the camera and the floor. You won't need them for this project.
Finally, move all remaining actors into a Lighting folder for better scene management.
Save your level.
Things are now ready on the UE5 end.
Back in Twinmotion. Again, make sure the provided TM2UE file is open.
Consider the scene graph. The project has been neatly organized using containers.
That's good news because although you could export the whole project in one sweep,
sometimes it pays off to break it into parts for easier management.
For example, you could hide all containers except Open Theater to export the hero building on its own.
The export process in itself is simple enough with the Datasmith Export feature accessible in the File menu.
For this project, you will need four distinct exports to cater separately for the hero building,
the context building surrounding it, vegetation and other props including characters and vehicles.
These Datasmith files have already been extracted and provided to you so you won't need to waste time on that process.
I will mention this though, setting the time of day prior to exporting may make a difference.
For example, animated cars at night display headlights and taillight effects that are based on decals.
These will not export if the time of day is set in daytime.
Next, we import these Datasmith into Unreal Engine.